these things are heavy
you know I'd like to thank everyone and
I like to think
kind words but I like to particularly
think the Board of Governors for making
this possible
it's amazing thing to have you know do I
have to give a speech everyone said what
I would like to say but anyway again
thank you and I'd like to thank my my
friends and supporters and people who
been there through the years you know
when I didn't have any money they were
there you know so I I thank you and
there was my family here and so I like
to give thanks to them but but but the
thing is when I went to UCLA it didn't
have really very many people of color
there but you said it was a special
place because it it made you create you
know it gave you a camera said let's go
out and make a film and don't come back
with something we seen you know and so
it had this built-in kind of philosophy
that you had to do something different
they didn't want to see anything that
that that seemed before because they had
they had a this end of the quarter
screening which they crucified you if
they seen anything that anything
actually that looked like Hollywood and
made it you know so it was a sort of an
anti how it would feel at the time but
it's since changed you know it's just
going to be more so but I think the the
the thing is that I had some really
wonderful teachers in one particular one
bath so right here is a documentary
filmmaker he did song and so long
I remember having difficulty when I
first went to UCLA in terms of not
knowing what to do because when I was
there they had the end of the quarter
screenings which were the best films
that the made at UCLA
and then but they were all about flower
children you know people who made films
at the Banger Canyon you know and they
were explaining or exploring their own
sexuality and stuff like that but where
I came from that wasn't an issue you
know it was it was about getting the job
and keeping a job you know and so those
are the kind of films I wanted to do and
it was Basile Wright who sort of pointed
me in that direction and the other thing
that would made it worthwhile and and
and and gave me some guidance was the
fact that there were people of color who
came and we had these meetings every
night you know and we we lived at UCLA
we went down to down to Westwood and
spent all night in the restaurants you
know till they kicked us out
and we talked about what is a black film
continuously you know what is our
responsibility what do we have to do and
out of that came like Julie - hi Kareem
and whole bunch of other people who are
well known at the moment and but we also
were a part of the civil rights movement
you know I grew up in the 50s and 60s
and in our obligation was to tell our
stories because Hollywood I don't mean
any disrespect but they had been
restored in our image since Birth of a
Nation you know so we it was incumbent
upon us to tell our our story our
narrative in our own way and so my my
interest in film and my ideas came from
that period I was working with a bunch
of students like myself who were
interested in making a difference and
using film as a as a means for social
change
I I you know in this business you get a
lot of negatives you know a lot of
rejection and my first rejection and
we've sort of appeared before you know
this business in a certain way it was
when I was in junior high school I had a
teacher it was a it was a history class
and I I had a speech in prepared and I
was very bad I guess this teacher
thought I was you know had mental
problems or something I don't know but
anyway so he would he
one day stood in front of the class and
and he looked over to Anthony walk down
there walk down the aisle and he's any
pointers different students he said he
said you're not gonna be anything and he
went down the aisle saying each one and
he came to me and pointed his finger
said you're not gonna be anything okay
and and and I remember that I remember
to this day in fact I've never forgotten
because it always had an impact on me
and because of that I never really felt
secure and what I was doing I always
thought that it was something that I
couldn't do and that it wouldn't have
any meaning or it just wasn't worthy and
so I never really felt that what I was
doing had any in spite of the fact I
studied with these other film people
that what we needed to do was make film
a tool for social change I still had
these problems of of thinking that what
I did had some significance and meaning
but things like this getting Awards like
this really make what were said in the
past and
you know what words were given and these
unkind words you know some people so I
mean people asked me about one that when
I was out in the and the red car
beginning interviews and pictures taken
and they said well what does it mean to
you getting this
well it means that you know getting
further and further away from this
stigma I mean leave this feeling that
you know I you know III that is not
going to have any meaning that that I I
don't have you know what it takes to
make things work but one of the things
that to what tonight does in a way you
know I the teacher always talked about
his name is mr. Baker and and I don't
know if he's still around but but I if
he is I do hope he reads the trades
but one other I'm probably rambling and
going on but there's one other thing I'd
like to count it off
I mean that I I had these words I've
written but they see they cut em off
because I'm not following strict so I
apologize for that because anyway anyway
but this last bit of story I tell you I
when I was working on the sleep with an
anger it was a company a TV company I
wanted to develop a story and we started
off with this other story I wanted but
they started to screw around and Mickey
one of the make changes but it was based
on a real-life story a lady who was
killed in my community by gang member
and and and the police talked her into
being and eyewitness and to testify in
court and she did but they gave her name
out in the press and the one of the gang
members killed her you know it could
kill this lady and I thought the whole
system fails I wanted to do a story
about that
and so this company started to screw
around with the script they wanted to
turn into you know something altogether
different it had no meaning in anything
and so I said no so I said let me do
something that that has no particular
meaning it's fictional make-believe and
so I start writing so people anger and
so there was a you know it's a story
about two generations and it's a family
situation where one of the sons follows
tradition the other son doesn't you know
he's sort of like wants to get rich and
he doesn't care he doesn't care about
anything he said for money so anyway
there was a long scene I wrote and so
the the folks the company that I was
developing a film with
what they had with how they had impact
on the film whether the story was that
your sin and your sin in a down line of
treatment and and efforts if it's
something they like they'll send a check
it was something they don't like they'll
tell you what the check is upstairs you
know so you would send something and
there was checking subsidies that means
go back and rewrite it you know and so
you saying something said well why don't
you send a check downstairs and put in a
mail
no well it could happen you know and so
yes this would go on and on and so there
was a scene that I wrote it was quite
long and so they rejected it and said
his check is offend me I said well I saw
the this biggest story on about a horton
Foote story and it's a long scene on the
veranda then went on and on and on and
he said yeah but you're not horton Foote
you know okay so I take the script back
and got another producer who's favored
doing the film they liked it and so many
years later that this would be surely
many years later I had finished the film
in Africa I was doing post-production in
Africa you know so I get this call from
the states and they said you we want to
give you an award I so fine I said but
you have to be here to get it I said
what I'm in Africa right now well you
have to be here and I said well can't
someone else get it they said no you
have to be here and so I'm getting kinda
angry a bit you know and so I'm trying
to be cool so as they well sure I can't
come he said no no no I said I mean
after he takes 14 hours to get there and
all
sort of thing but you have to be here
okay so I said well what is the war
that's it
well it's the hoarding foot and writing
award so I said I'll be there so anyway
thanks thanks a great deal
[Applause]